abbiamo l'annuncio mega importante da
fare nella pagina di happy with non
copriamo messaggio da due anni compare
questo tutte robe che a voi non
interessano tranne quest'ultima
quest'ultima frase penso che dia un
sacco di emozioni
sto unicamente lavorando al sequel e sta
andando bene ci sarà il pp2 questo
canale andrà avanti anche fino al 2040
perché sappiamo che è prevista è durato
negli ultimi quant'è che faccio video
sette anni 7 anni quindi sono sette anni
di happy with e faremo altri sette anni
tranquilli appena uscì ai primi due
porca vacca
nel frattempo l'ex rockol gameplay di
oggi ragazzo noto subito ragazzi che nei
livelli di tra i più nuovi quindi quelli
fatti oggi c'è fa vj e il rutelliano
ecco questo non lo vorremmo in elpis due
fortunate avente però facciamo lo fa vi
saluta e vi sono fa vigili mangia
nutella cosa non è finita nel 2014 la
nutella però che ti piace il mio primo
livello è l'ultima cosa non andare
indietro in staccato dietro ok la prima
cosa che ovviamente faccio ci saranno
delle mine pazzesche ci sarà qualcosa di
incredibile dove non c'è niente
sufficiente mi ha trovato alla fine c'è
un troll face gigante con su scritto non
c'e niente dietro che ho fatto solo
perdere un sacco di the party che quando
hai fatto lungo la vasta smette non
arriva ringhiere tronto andiamo hai
fatto amico mio
ti prego fammi vedere mostrami
attenzione io avevo detto di non venire
parole niente estiva aiutami non ti
posso aiutare londra è solo
dar non sono ancora molta attenzione
posso salvarmi e si salva non è vero
dunque non oso pensare è previsto con
tutti i miei livelli sarà ti prego dimmi
che mi cade in testa
peccato sarebbe stato incredibile ko
cara
ciao raga medi che scherzavo a posto
vado bellissimo ce l'ho fatta c'è un
cannone rientro ci entrò vale
sicuramente sarei stato così bravo da
fare una specie di roba dove si può
entrare nel cannone venice parato gli
arrivi direttamente in quel punto di cai
calibrato prima vero zio
vediamo vediamo dai calibrato prima vero
lai calibrato un po male perché c'è uno
shock prof a niente miotto titola la
l'arrivo bello grosso livello fa vige il
modellino cioè nel senso che se fosse
molto più brutto
all'alba del 2020 comunque vedo che i
livelli sono un po migliorati
stranamente anche se non è niente di che
ma meglio di quanto pensassi celso
caduto next bello il nome comunque fa
vige il modellino mi piace altri validi
fa vj no però abbiamo un album da oggi
il 99 per cento lescaut made by ninja
ping maiale ninja porca vacca quest'anno
schivata benissimo aiuto mamma mia con
lo ski vate queste
madonna come me la sono meritata
vittoria bellissima avendo che si è
svegliata la community di è più il
secondo il creatore ha appena annunciato
ai più is ii spacebar di sisa rent fly p
toilet tensione del gol bellissimo e
flachi board con la toilette ma ricordo
che ho mai pensato finite nel cesso col
suo caduto sono ancorate sono ancora su
non so come con che fisica con che
fisica è impossibile ma penso anche la
gamba fa niente non ci ho mai pensato di
mettere un razzo sotto il cesso
fichissima bellissima idea però ci sarà
un punto dove arriverò alla fine oppure
continuiamo a me va bene poi sono
stancato di diverso tono molto in alto
lo rifaccio accendi 18 ok ok a posto
jigsaw wheels ai 60 secondi trova la
chiave che se a madonna bellissimo ma i
saw l'enigmista switch le ips cut and
cap taglia la corda non posso tagliare o
qua sotto c'è qualcosa c'è qualcosa con
ha sì perché se non vi si apre la faccia
in 60 secondi ok la bellissima ha fatto
benissimo martello martella qua qua non
si smantella qua martella il tubo da che
ciò il martello qualcosa lo sto martello
tira dai ma non si svita quello porca
vacca non ragazzi non so fare
sto perdendo devo saltare cosa devo fare
qua capt c'è un tizio là sopra non
capisco colpirlo switcher o forse c'è
una mattone esco lasciare una mattonella
cacciavite xvi taqwa vita
prendi questo taglia quello ok la tizia
c'è ora dentro a chiave e cordiale dai
ho vinto per due secondi e 77 decimi
madonna meno male
meno male che mi è venuto vedovo
spaccare la mattonella se non avrei mai
capito prove 99 per cento in posti come
questo mi sembrano impossible tarato
bene effettivamente però però non facile
che questo è normale se non sarebbe
imposti col ma ovviamente io riesco che
se non riuscissi non mi chiamerei di
certo armando long spyphone xd scappare
un salto decente quest'anno spyphone
normale immagino normale ma difficile
vabbè madonna auto l'hai fatto lungo zio
e non parlo di quello che pensi
parlo dello spike pole ma devo seguire
una linea va tra l'altro sta la tecnica
non c'era mai stata in uno spy phone
seguire una linea finissimo attenzione
[Musica]
va bene
rob soccer no bellissimo c'è un robot
soccer subito attenzionerà cristiano
profit 3 lavoro facevano film the chain
decente ovviamente perché sei quelli
normali facciamo tutti famolo decente la
partenza non è male
il continuo invece è male perché mi
servono le braccia per fare i rokes
inganno già persa una quindi magari non
perdo anche l'altra che dite
ed è difficile non perdere le braccia
year of thing perché la forza delle
aereo delle corde vendola in inglese
tiravi al braccio che un piacere
protettivamente ce l'ho fatta
sono sette anni che dico cose che non
dovrei dire devo stare zitto e io parlo
da anni parlo io parlo un livello fatto
finito non sono morto perché esplodi
esplosa la famiglia
ok attenzione questa è buona è
bellissimo allora se mi devi fare girare
le balle non me le far girare adesso
perché per cortesia ma crediamo che la
farà ricorso
[Musica]
meglio di prima ma il forno richards
byford guanti spy come avete fatto
stavolta non per questo è molto corto
giudicare la pendenza
scherzavo è molto più grande di quanto
pensassi porco demonio questo è giusto
parcak a questo è giusto che si viaggia
vissuto già è tutto già questo è giusto
questo quell'ultimo l'ultimo giusto
grazie grazie a tutti
suor altro medium così abbiamo fatto
tutto tranne il bowl troppi ne facciamo
questo purtroppo ragazzi perché mancano
quelli effettivamente per oggi però
texture penn this game
ovviamente quando faccio svoltato
ragazzi un po una sorta di relax time
perché ormai però il prossimo al colo
dietro amico mio
vale mai fatto di impossible ho detto
sta cagata annunciarono medica e invece
non lo sarei meritato e lì non beccarlo
però e pixi di justin justin bieber
fighi bataille che bello ma il più bel
livello mai visto su è più il finissimo
farvi vedere justin round 3 fight perché
la mia grande 122 stabilito pin
azione non è neanche facile tra l'altro
riuscito la prima volta per caso
eccolo è cascato l'altro è veramente
orribile perché ciò la lancia infilata
nella pancia
ecco one boltro one ball una una palla
quindi proprio due ottiene solo st palla
venne un mostro che sembra facile ma non
lo è perché alla fine non cambia niente
se ci pensate fate finta anzi ancora
difficile perché in tutte le dovrebbero
esserci un sacco di scompartimenti con
su scritto palle più la morte si toglie
quindi cose positive invece non c'è
niente c'è solo morte e vittoria quindi
è molto più difficili un volto normale
realtà sembra più facile ma non lo è
perché ripeto c'è solo morte
quindi è veramente molto difficili molto
normale del mare
[Musica]
ce l'ha fatta il primo tentativo
veramente esausto ma soddisfatto perché
ho giocato bene sono troppo contento che
sky più il nuovo devoluti però sono
contentissimo che skype 2 perché almeno
proviamo un po di differenza sono sette
anni che tutte le domeniche gioca la
stessa cosa cioè per me come mi avesse
come sarà annunciato un figlio cioè come
se è come se è più ismi avesse detto
sono incinta
ok quindi io faccio video il messicano
la prossima volta quindi bella a tutti i
ragazzi il messicano e ci vediamo al
prossimo video iscrivetevi schiaccia
dalla campanellina la campane l'itas e
noi ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]